[Music]
in fool me once news submitted by ice
climbers film twice ice climbers do
really good in obstacle races I just
know ice climbers as the characters and
super smash brothers die and the actual
ice climbers yeah like in Super Smash
they're those cute little characters you
know in these parkas and but then when
one dies you could still go on with the
with the other ones still alive I hate
that character super hard to use yeah
very hard to yeah it's nice it's not a
very like easy character to use so in
fool me what's news these are mistakes
that smart people never make twice I
love click baby articles like this
because we're just make yourself really
really dumb there's an umbrella [ __ ]
term I mean uh you know criteria for all
smart people let me see what I do let me
see what I do I feel like I've make this
a thousand times
let me hear let me hear what we want to
read this article just because I don't
want to find out that I'm done uh-huh no
I know we're headed yeah yeah pretty
much
tell Matt something and really smart at
something mhm
Oh everyone's done when they're
emotional alright if someone could be
smartest [ __ ] just get them
emotionally riled up
they'll be dumb as [ __ ] I know number
one believing in someone or something
that's too good to be true so they so
smart people will never make that same
mistake twice
well I'm stupid cuz i gamble and that
happens way more than twice they have
here it says some people are so
charismatic and so confident that it can
be tempting to follow anything they say
they speak endlessly of how successful
their businesses are how well like they
are who they know and how many
opportunities they can offer you sounds
like a lady me huh sounds like this City
to me LA yeah other people do that here
oh like that
yeah and is that Oh like drinking the
kool-aid from very charismatic people
yeah that mean yeah so that would be
someone that's too good to be true right
then it says well it's of course true
that some people really are successful
and really want to help you smart people
only need to be tricked once before they
start to think twice about a deal that
sounds too good to be true yep I've
learned that lesson so many times feel
like that's a very yeah you're right
because it's such an elevating you know
everybody's learned that list it doesn't
matter if it's happened to you one time
or five times or ten times but we've all
had to learn it man I've been warning
some people doing they don't [ __ ]
listen to me man people get caught up in
like the quick scheme so much like what
they hear they hear and they're like oh
my god that's like a deal of a lifetime
and it's like [ __ ] that's why
it's too good to be true yeah I told a
personal friend about something like
that recently didn't care saw all the
opportunity and what I told them was you
don't get this much of something without
somebody asking you for a favor in
return and what happened was when it
came time for him to return the favor he
was like I don't know I suppose we're
serving favor back well you just [ __ ]
yourself over there you go boom
yeah I think when I joined a pyramid
scam and then like why I knew it was a
pyramid scam and all this stuff happened
and then like I started seeing these
kind of guys that would be like aromatic
big ballers all that stuff same with
like get-rich-quick schemes right like
you you do it and you realize it's my
fault I was greedy like that's the
reason why people get fooled is they
prey on your greed but people don't want
to believe that they're greedy there is
they're just know it was his fault he
[ __ ] not man like I take full
responsibility I was greedy
I wanted something fast for nothing we
live in an instant gratification society
right we want results now it's like I
was talking some teachers who lied do
some talks at university sometimes we
talk about well yeah whatever but people
you know school sometimes bring me out
and you know the big thing I was asked
like the organizers were what are things
that you want to talk about what are
problems that like kids are facing these
days that they weren't facing a few
years ago and they're like well because
of like because
Instagram because of social media the
use of how accessible everything is
people expect to be amazing at something
right away because if like for example
if you want to take up drawing and you
like follow you know all these you know
amazing artists on Instagram all of a
sudden you know you just see the
finished product constantly and you
don't see the process so you know you
don't admire or appreciate or respect
the grind and the the like the time that
it takes to get there is that cut what's
that saying is that everybody wants to
eat the cookie but they don't want to
see how it's made you know it's that
same [ __ ] really
maybe I'm just making up stuff I like
this know how it's made oh is it or is
it saying that's the way the cookie
crumbles smells really good um basically
I want talking about cookies no no man
that was my vibrator I had dildo longer
yeah yeah yeah yeah plot twist yeah no
that's actually one of them here so
failing to delay gratification is what
you were just talking about hmm well you
know smart people know that
gratification doesn't come quickly and
hard work comes long before the reward
mm-hmm so there's a study done on
children like in elementary school that
they did back in a day to determine if
there is a characteristic for successful
like what makes a successful human being
right and it was the kids that were able
to delayed gratification ended up as
adults being successful in money and
relationships and all sorts of other
things the way they did the study was is
like I think they use cookies or candy
but but anyways they're like they'll
tell the kid you could have one now or
you could have ten later which would you
do and then the kids that were able to
wait for ten later they did the study
throughout their lifetime and figured
out majority of them ended up being very
successful the kids that were an instant
like I need it now
you know I would have taken the cookie
right that in there
a hundred percent just need one I don't
need ten thick after five anyway yeah
you start rationalizing it like dude why
would you want tell you can you take all
we did slow we didn't really yeah dude
like you'll eat the ten really fasten it
all online as you will end it at the
same time all right next one doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different results
the definition of insanity yeah yeah
that's what Albert Einstein said oh yeah
people failed relationships
alright yeah I do the same thing get
into the same fights person likewise oh
yeah with the same dude with the same
face tattoos and you think you think
he's too big of a Korean pastor it's
nothing gonna happen dude I love those
guys great losers
this next one says operating without a
budget so smart people know that it
takes a budget and like for you to stick
to a budget like personally and
professionally it forces us to make
thoughtful choices about what we want
and need that's true I'm real stupid
real stupid
Amazon oh I'm all for for right now no
no I I think I first won maybe but I
don't I'm not good at delaying
gratification like I'm very very very
impatient you got to come right now dude
he never jacks off that is the first
thing in the morning everybody knows I'm
a lazy [ __ ] bro I understand why do you
think that's a hard one usually no okay
okay maybe maybe I'm 50% that's still an
Asian fail that feels like a zero yeah I
might as well be zero I'm almost this
close dude for making my next year's
resolution to delete Amazon off my phone
Wow [ __ ]
oh yeah I bought I buy so much [ __ ] we
give me all the boxes that come in it's
your name on it for our house
[Laughter]
what are you talking about that guy
heels in the yellow you don't benefit
from that oh yes I do spank bank
all right next one losing sight of the
big picture oh yeah hmm yeah I hate the
big picture because it's so far away
give me the cooking now I'm still
thinking about that cookie it's like
where's the cookie yet
dad you promised me a cookie attendant
okay yeah
where's the [ __ ] cook that [ __ ] is
warm actually that would have been the
trick if they're like you want one cold
cookie now or 10 warm cookies there oh
yeah yeah wait for the 20 warm I walked
into many a pizza shop and there's a
slice right in front of me and I'll be
like no I'll wait wait you make me a
fresh pizza yeah you're real tough you
know Barry was cooking it ass he just
came on this shown here he knows your
girlfriend's name too like the D yeah I
know a lot about Mary no but I'll tell
you this though yo this is truth her
cookies
[ __ ] hell a good dude she made this
cookie thing from this recipe that she
learned from Lynn's friend [ __ ]
amazing best cookies I've ever had has
chocolate chip with the little oatmeal
in it dude oh it's [ __ ] good I had it
the day of fresh out the oven and we had
it the next day after Thanksgiving
[ __ ] good dude
I [ __ ] love this woman and her
cookies the other foot hmm
but the cookies don't you called it
trash you can't go oh I see that as a
joke Mario's food isn't trash it's not
good it depends if she makes it in an
instant pot it's pretty decent oh yeah
we did I press the wrong button I
figured I was making Esme Canadians I
know I was making
chicken soup or something like that and
then like I suppose get clear broth and
came out brown wait hold on a second
let's not how you supposed to make
chicken soup no idea what else we just
did the whole raw chicken and you threw
it and I remember it was bad but I
supposed to be clear broth that's the
pictures showed us and it was brown bra
you're following instruction I don't
remember
maybe it was a blue egg so chicken soup
typically you make the stock first with
the chicken you take those meats and
then you add it in after you don't put
raw chicken and then you create the soon
so it's made with the stock from the
bone you I blame you that I felt yo I
could make so I just been eating my own
so what I love about Thanksgiving is not
the day of is a day after well done
we're talking about yeah well guess what
I was gonna make ya'll chicken news no
you all right next one not doing your
homework so that's not sure I'd ever do
does it all the time when we all do our
hunger when you you would like research
like a crazy mofo yeah but in school I
wish it was we didn't see the purpose in
it but this is this is what I realize is
the majority of the world does not do
homework like if you train at a gym or
whatever right like if you're doing your
homework there they don't take it home
and try to do more beyond that and and
the way that we approach any hobby or
business it's that's exactly what we do
so I'm like oh [ __ ] I didn't realize
that that is not a normal trait it's not
no it's not people just going to start
buying [ __ ] no no not like that but like
the way that they apply themselves into
hobbies and things majority like like
this it like the person I got more time
whatever that's been gone for like five
years
but since they only trained at the gym
they don't really get any better yeah
I'm not messing my shadowboxing the
shower or trying to button to brush my
teeth
so and I'm saying that there's a lot of
people that do I'm saying that but the
way like for example sample size right
like you go to your whole gym and you
think about the majority of people they
go there to train that's their homework
they don't train at home
I only practice when there's nothing
wrong with that
there's a lot of people that do that and
and I think that's what they mean by
homework right not schoolwork yeah sure
and then they're also saying like
strolling into an important meeting
unprepared like right all right because
you just preparation hot like right
handed one time and you're like no
that's not right exactly because that's
a smart person yeah but I do have idea I
do have opinions about the cart like the
educational system right cuz builds a
hundred years ago it's not it's
definitely not made for the modern day
and like it's just so sad that's what
we're doing the kids were like locking
them up when they should be you know
built off the factory system right and
efficient I mean there's a reason for it
to like if you want everyone to think
the same it's perfect if you want to
build a nation it's perfect like how do
you standardize something where people
from New York all the way to LA Ayana
think the same or have at least same
basics right yeah or at least we all
agree on the same history kind of you
know yeah but for individualistic
thinking no fur it's our yeah it sucks
yeah but it's great nation building yep
[Music]